[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment I am your host
Walter Bonet dziak before we get started
with the introduction of our panelists
here today I wanted to thank you guys
for commenting on the last few videos
and suggesting what we should cover on
the show please keep commenting keep
telling us what you want to see on the
show and we will make sure to look over
it we're reading all those comments and
we're gonna try to cover as much of what
you guys want us to cover as possible we
are listening so thank you very much for
commenting the show length so we talked
about last time trying to make these
shows longer we all want them longer
unfortunately right now it's not going
to be possible until our audience grows
a little bit more so the way you can
help with that go ahead and share the
video around to your friends anyone who
you think would be interested in this
kind of show this kind of like panel
type discussion and the more you know
the bigger we get the more likely it
will be for us to have longer episodes
once in a while we'll still be able to
have longer ones and we'll talk about
that later but we always wanted to say I
also wanted to say that I know that a
lot of people in the comments talking
about why aren't we talking about comic
specifically fear not folks okay and a
couple of weeks we'll really we will be
doing a mostly all comic book show and
remember to always stick around because
at the end of the show we always always
have our Pick of the Week which is
always at least one comic book talking
about somehow tying in to what our main
discussion is so okay
also on this episode make sure you stick
around for after our Supergirl
discussion because we're gonna have an
interview with our very own James J Roz
he is going to give us a little tour of
the costumes and stuff for a nostalgia
critic
so Heather our friend is going to
interview him and that's gonna be after
this titillating discussion okay yes
okay well let me introduce you guys
first okay to my left you know this guy
his name is mr. Brian Porter how's it
going there good how are you I'm doing
okay
very talk about Supergirl
mm well he's ready okay and over here
who'd we get what's butchering Ayanna
Wade ina way yeah
we are going to be talking about season
one of Supergirl today everybody
Supergirl is a show that is kind of
divisive as right now it has not been
renewed for a season two but we're here
to talk about season one and I wanted to
know your guys thoughts on it
so the first thing I want to talk about
is the characters on the show so we have
Supergirl we have Jimmy Olsen we have a
couple recognizable characters from the
Superman comics and stuff and a bunch of
new characters so what do you guys think
of this cast and the characters so very
charismatic cast
it's very earnest attempt at Supergirl
herself I really like Melissa a lot
I like Kyler is really likable whether
or not you like her character I really
like her as her character I really like
Jimmy Olsen and win like their little
trio like that going on is just super
super likable
I like the cast okay poor they got a
good dynamic together win for the most
part is pretty okay like he had some
better better moments later on in the
season Melissa Benoist is fantastic and
Supergirl she's so likable and she's
believable she like looks great in the
costume she is fantastic I love
everything about her Jimmy Olsen that's
not Jimmy Olsen that's I know we I don't
why is it not Jimmy Olsen you take okay
Jimmy Olsen medium height nerdy
redheaded kind of you know not loser but
like he just follows everybody he's not
at his own man like I think a lot of the
time and you turn him into this six-two
model type black guy is full of charisma
and charm and you know he's dating Lucy
Lane and then he has a thing for
Supergirl and they're together and it's
just like Supergirl would never date
Jimmy Olsen in the comics ever ever I
don't think that would happen and it's
just it didn't seem like Jimmy Olsen
that guy's character worked in the show
but I don't think that was Jimmy Olsen
it didn't even seem like the new Jimmy
Olsen I've ever seen okay
and what do you think of his thoughts on
Jimmy Olsen
I disagree I think
super charismatic which you did say but
I like the progression they're able to
do together with Supergirl and Jimmy I
think it fits I think it like actually
there I was sort of rooting for win for
a little bit but that I've changed my
tune and I'm really encouraged I seem
attitude I think with Jimmy like with
how kind of awkward and you know stuff
she is in the show like regular Jimmy
Olsen they could have had a thing you
know when is that though you want to be
like three really awkward terrible
fumbling maybe like they took Jimmy
Olsen kind of gave most of his
personality traits to win because they
needed to you know up the hot factor
it's like they did it they didn't do it
as a kid he didn't lead another white
guy in the show though that's they they
cast a little diversely which is nice to
see
then just make a specific character to
cast that guy I mean like just don't
don't change a character because okay we
need to make it diverse and we need a
hot character and we need to have like a
different personality it's like it's a
completely different personality for
Jimmy Olsen we have to talk about
Martian Manhunter slash Hank Henshaw
Yeah right slash John Jones he's he's in
the show and I think like that character
really grew on me as the show went along
as the whole show did it even at first
you know with everything I was kind of
like oh no but as it went along I get
more and more comfortable with it and he
was one of the main reasons why I really
liked Martian Manhunter in the show I
know what you think I loved my marsh
Manhunter I was super stoked when we
realized who he was when he did its
whole revealing thing I I was I really
liked him as a character so I was really
excited to have him as a character on
the show
and I liked you that because he's so
powerful that they kind of had to keep
him reserved by being able to like keep
his secret identity I would say and then
also there being white Martians that
could say he was and stuff I think
there's a lot of room to grow with his
character now specifically and I and I
really like the way they covered it the
whole they totally went into his story
back on Mars and yeah all that which was
really really
cool I like just look I thought his look
was really great they handled it pretty
well I really liked him on the show I
hope you see a bunch bunch more of him
I agree Porter I like to wanted to
initially I wasn't a super huge fan then
I go tank and show my cyborg superman
that's gonna be cool and then right
martian manhunter I'm like huh what how
they you know he got that name and all
that stuff and he is John Jones and it's
just like okay that's interesting choice
but him as you know Hank Henshaw John
John it's like who's a great character
outside of being Martian Manhunter I
liked him a lot he felt very Jon Jones I
wanted to go to a couple of the
positives of the show we're gonna go
positives and negatives what was some of
your ads favorite episodes
you get a couple lines oh yeah I liked
the the Toyman one right what was that
one called a childish childish thing yes
that one was super good I liked too
there was there was like a deeper Ness
to that episode talking kind of about
like mental instability and genetically
like Winn was really scared that he like
had a predisposition to like go a little
crazy and stuff room and they handled
that really well I thought I liked
world's finest the crossover between
flash yeah let's talk about that episode
okay it was great so yeah they you know
flash comes into the Supergirl universe
they kind of explained it on flash like
just this past week and even though this
episode is like weeks old yes a month or
something
it wasn't like on flash they kind of
just like he's gone in you back and he's
just like going back and then just go on
with what they're talking about so it
was kind of just a waste of time on the
flash but Supergirl was a bigger deal
obviously I actually thought the episode
was pretty weak except for Keira and
Vega and berry berry talking mm-hmm
you know them interacting and stuff is
really cool oh yeah I loved seeing them
together like they work really well off
each other and stuff so I thought like
their chemistry was great just the
episode itself I thought it was kind of
lame their chemistry was awesome I I I'm
sure they probably won't do another
crossover but if they did maybe I'd be
on board I thought was great like they
were so awkward and adorable
gather like I thought they worked well
so much like it was the chemistry was
perfect and it's just it was such a good
episode is very light-hearted for the
most part in the way that they felt
together was great and then the rest of
the episode yeah I was a little weak but
I did like silver banshee silver banshee
or whatever I thought she looked great
character was the episode falling when
you know was a really good emotional
ride I think introducing red kryptonite
and stuff with car and everything that
was a great episode yeah I thought that
was really cool by the way I'm gonna
just hot now yeah and the and there's
you know there's a big fallout from that
like this whole state doesn't trust her
now like that is cool that it was a nice
little closer than world's finest right
it was a little bit yeah it was a nice
little twist down there as far as like
the best emotional moment for me for the
entire season was probably um when cara
comes out of the red kryptonite days hmm
and she like she broke what's-her-name's
arm and she just instantly starts crying
it's just there was so much heart oh
yeah there's like that it's testament to
uh most of the noise acting abilities as
Supergirl and I thought was a really
really strong moment for her but my
favorite emotional part of the whole
season so yeah it was great the the
black mercy episode for the girl who has
everything I thought was really good it
was yeah yeah I did like that based off
of the Superman story yeah that was that
was handled really well I think yeah
that's one of the nice things about the
show revolving around Supergirl too is
like the difference between Supergirl
and Smallville Smallville you sort of
only get earths and like his path once
he's here where supergirls been half
here half on Krypton so you really like
she knows what she's missing she wasn't
just raised here as a baby and this is
all she's known like she knows exactly
the people that have died she knows and
like grew up with them she knows like
world wise like the difference is she
remembers like different creatures and
stuff she remembers like having a home
and all the all the cool things she's
missing out on and
that was one of those episodes that was
really really apparent and because it's
the whole ripping her out of heaven
yes stuff that they were talking about
definitely really emotionally effective
and they've been having Alex happen to
go in there and try and save her I
thought that all worked really well it
was good the whole Alex like talking to
the the mom hologram though was pretty
weak as far as her she she that was that
character like I like the actress and I
liked some of the stuff like a
relationship with Kara is great and
everything just she makes really stupid
decisions and she's really overdramatic
sometimes I just cry for no reason it
was a it was a good a good episode as a
whole yeah although one of my favorite
episodes as far as emotion goes was
bizarre oh really you know I did not
like the fact that they even used a
bizarre-o in any capacity that is
Superman's villain like it translates I
get it had like a tinge of derp I just
liked her connection to it and all that
stuff and they changed liveWires whole
origin story to be Supergirl as well
like it was pretty much the same thing
right but they did it with her instead
it was similar okay we're gonna go on to
the negatives we'll trying to get to is
pretty quick so supergirls powers are
like inexcusably inconsistent in the
show she gets caught in quicksand in an
episode yeah like you serious Supergirl
gets caught in quicksand
that was she can't fly in space yeah
even though even though they said oh you
know you might be stronger than your
cousin it's like if you're stronger than
your cousin you can totally find space
there is no gravity in space you're not
gonna be able to fly what yeah it was
you can't generate thrust I was like oh
she can't breathe in space I'm like she
doesn't breathe like us though she
doesn't need to breathe she can be
underwater just like Superman she could
be in the very happened a couple times
where she's like without air
I don't doubt I don't understand yeah
just very inconsistent with how strong
she is or how weak she is like it just
doesn't it doesn't add up hopefully if
the show comes back they'll be able to
improve on that kind of thing okay one
of talking about the the handling of
Superman here bad really really really
bad well I was saying earlier to you
that they first off don't say his name
in the first episode at all and then
like 9 10 minutes in to the second
episode they finally said it and I'd
like felt like I was holding my breath
that whole time being like okay quote
man in blue I'm Anna steel yet your
cousin whatever like they were going
through all of them like to the point
where like I couldn't think of anything
else yeah it was like obvious that they
were trying not to say see right and
then they finally said it yeah so they
try to have him in the show without him
actually being in the show which is is a
completely backwards decision if you
want to really focus on Supergirl which
is what the showrunners and writers and
everything been talking about then just
say he's off world or something they
made a deal in one of us but then it
comes right back a couple in Slater just
say he's been offworld or something for
like a few months he hasn't been there
and then when you eventually are getting
around to casting Superman if you want
to actually be a minor character on the
show then you can do that but having him
in these little you seen from far away
he's flying right towards and the the
penultimate episode he's flying like
right towards Kerr and then he like just
drops down perhaps yeah like you see and
then nobody worries about him till later
right and then his his his mind is
affected because he was raised on earth
by the me that was so are you kidding me
yeah yeah there's never really a fully
formed episode like there's some stuff
like the red kryptonite episode and
bizarre episode that like the emotional
highs of the episode are great and I
totally get sucked into it I am on board
like sucked in with those emotional
moments but once you're outside of that
like the actual story comes in and it
just it kind of takes an episode
sometimes no I mean I don't know like
they've got the formula down a little
bit that needs some tweaking
they they've got room to grow but I feel
like it's there like they've got pricey
stuff that's there right they can build
off they can build off and make it
better I think I think there's a lot of
potential a lot of wasted potential for
this show fire a couple of the writers
like
seriously some of that writing is really
bad I agree I like Supergirl overall I
want to see it come back for season two
I want to see it improve I think it has
room to improve
yeah so final thoughts on Supergirl I
like it I want to see season two it's
okay
season two would be better if it was on
like the CW there's a lot of potential
and it has a lot of growing to do for me
that's really be okay with it like if I
don't see it next year I don't care oh
well
Supergirl I think would fit really well
in this CW universe I mean it's got that
light heartedness that kind of flash
does and I think you know having those
two characters crossover more if they
were in like the same universe I think
we always make for some great TV yeah
it's unfortunate that we probably might
not see that because it hasn't been
announced if it's going to be renewed
yet
[Music]
oh hey guys it's Heather I'm here at the
heart and soul of Channel awesome and
I'm here to talk to Jim who is also kind
of the heart and soul of channel awesome
he is the set designer costume designer
guy who does all the things we're gonna
check out some of the costumes from the
Batman V Superman nostalgia critic
review that just came out last week it
was awesome you guys did a great job so
let's check out some of the costumes
this stack Superman costume was just the
costume that we had we have used it for
the Man of Steel review and stuff like
that too so just use that so this is the
Batman costume that you ended up with
and exactly so it's just a cheap muscle
suit from a costume store and then a
cheap long-sleeve t-shirt from the
thrift store so this is just a piece of
craft foam that I cut out in the shape
and with some fabric adhesive glued
right through there this is just the
Keaton one that I had to open up the the
jaw line a bit and cut up the cut off
the symbol and cut the ears down and as
you can see like yeah the ears aren't
staying together but yeah there's
nothing there's nothing really sticks to
latex and other than more latex so I
didn't have enough time to rebuild the
latex after I cut it down with some mass
building latex so it's just double-sided
tape that's kind of holding the ears so
unfortunately during the review Doug was
constantly having
years back and keep them from popping
open so then yeah Wonder Woman that was
my favorite costume that you guys had it
looked awesome but of course it we used
I think in the hocus pocus review I was
warned by Beth it was a different color
I hate surprises spray painted it red
and then using some craft foam I quickly
cut out some patterns and stuff like
that in shapes and literally just kind
of velcroed it right to the the belt the
same thing it's just craft foam attached
to a belt and then this cheap crown I
had lying around turned upside down that
was a headband with some is that garbage
is just a garbage can lid that we use as
one of the drum tops for the Mad Max
review that I just quickly so Jim what
is your favorite costume that you've
made for any nostalgia critic review um
that's a tough one but I I think that
furiosa are the kurios eye costume that
I made for Tamara for the Mad Max review
was probably my favorite that one came
together super well it was another like
really quick thing but like the
mechanical arm and just how great camera
looked in that costume that was like the
most rewarding I think I'm making that
one and how it all came together she
felt great as the character and in the
costume and that's exactly what you want
as a costume maker
you know like mythic character to
immediately immerse there's like be deaf
character and they put the costume on so
that was like yeah that's my bar I think
my favorite so thanks a lot for talking
to us today Jim back to you guys in the
studio
although we are in the studio stop all
right thanks a lot guys okay we're gonna
run down a quote a couple quick news
items right now first thing Killing Joke
the animated movie has been confirmed to
be rated R you're gonna go all out with
this thing I am so excited I don't think
it had to be absolutely had to be radar
to make it a great movie but this is
going to make sure that they can stick
to the comic and really go as far as
they have to with this so what do you
guys think of rated R Killing Joke
Hayama we've seen Rhiannon our totally
works
so I think you have all mine right I
have all my face met great it's even if
they don't have to go all the way with
it I don't think they'll push it I mean
absolutely not but it's nice to have the
freedom to do what they need to do right
I know Bruce Timm was saying like he's
like we we didn't have it in mind like
we need to go our he's like the studio
said you have the opening for and our
he's like so if we happen to get there
and in the process of making this film
so be it but we're not pushing for it
and that is the best way to look at a
movie like if you have the content where
you could go in our but if you're just
trying to make it as good as possible
and you happen to be in our that's it
don't go for an art because you want to
go for it are go for making the movie
and whatever happens happens that's the
best way to do it and so I'm super
excited I cannot wait that's what I'm
looking forward to that of anything
that's coming out for whenever it's
going out okay
next news item sci-fi the channel sci-fi
is close to securing a deal on a pilot
order for David s Goyer Superman prequel
series Krypton which is which supposed
to be set in the Man of Steel universe
and it's gonna Center on Superman's
grandfather because everyone wants to
see that as he fights for the shamed and
ostracized house of El according to
Variety the series will be set two
generations before Superman's home
planet was destroyed so I don't want to
see this whatsoever know what do you
guys think of Krypton on sci-fi I don't
care in this light it's like ever the
last news item here Robert Downey jr.
has been confirmed to be inspiring
homecoming that's exciting news in some
form or another he's gonna have some
kind of role inspiring homecoming that's
great also Michael Keaton those villain
rumors that were out a couple weeks ago
that may be done because their reports
out right now that he is not going oh
yeah he left talks for he's not gonna be
in the movie so what do you guys think
of Michael Keaton out Robert do need
Robert Downey jr. in well it depends who
they get instead of Michael Keaton like
might be someone cool we don't know yeah
I would love to see Beetlejuice in
spider-man I mean what uh I just think
he's a great actor and I think he could
do bad well so I mean you don't want to
get luck nuts let's get nuts I just I
just thought it would have been cool to
see him but yeah
there's so much you know I'm glad he's
gonna be in there helps tie it in I
think it's great right
angry with that okay we're gonna go on
to the pic of the week here and it is
Supergirl related this is a heavy book
they suggest and you might want to read
up a little bit on before you read this
but this is the big one man this crisis
on Infinite Earths now the reason why
I'm picking crisis on Infinite Earths
for the Supergirl pic of the week is
because Supergirl famously dies in this
book I mean it's on the cover it's not a
spoiler is on the cover this is like 30
years old if you haven't figured that
one out by now sorry but yeah this is a
really interesting story you know it
rebooted the DC Universe and they're
kind of they've done it like seven times
since then especially with her origin
right she has a lot of different origins
a lot of different yeah starting points
for that character and personalities and
stuff right so this is where she dies
for the I think the first time and she
was gone for a while afterwards so if
you want to see the last moments of this
version of Supergirl I think she check
this out it's a good read it's confusing
at some parts take some notes take some
notes something like that but it's worth
it to check it out and it's a big piece
of comic book history so check out
crisis on Infinite Earths that's my
comic book pick of the week look I'm
look at that comic book you guys happy
yet okay we're gonna get there right but
this is something for you guys now a lot
of comments I've seen people want to see
our favorite DC animated movies while
next week that is what we're gonna give
you our favorite DC animated movies are
gonna be coming to awesome comics next
week I'm so excited for that that is
much more of my forte and I love the
animated stuff and I love to talk about
it so we're gonna talk about that next
week on the show okay Porter where can
we find in the social medias
facebook.com slash awesome Porter okay
dianna Facebook Twitter Instagram father
where is it is it lower thirds that's
what we call in the biz
okay you can follow me on twitter at
awesome underscore Walter for all your
Zack Snyder needs and they played on the
show last week that was a lot of fun I'm
sad if you haven't seen a dog like
that's a lot of fun yeah it was a lot of
fun okay everybody so until next week
we'll be talking about DC animated
movies come back for that
so until then for these people here I'm
ranae's yak and we will see you on the
next page
[Music]
you